We Begin tonight with this news
bombshell new developments for James
Comer's investigation into the possible
Biden family Syndicate or Enterprise if
you live in Georgia if you prefer very
real allegations of bribery and money
laundering we have a lot of new details
tonight anyone any of you ever hear of a
guy named Robert L Peters ask yourself
anyone know that name anybody raise your
hand if you you know you do okay
according to documents we've now
uncovered from the National Archives and
emails retrieved from zero experienced
Hunter Biden's laptop Robert Peters
appears to be a pseudonym for your
President Joe Biden when he was using as
vice president to conduct official
government business Biden likely trying
to hide these communications from prying
eyes or public records requests now the
chairman of the house oversight and
accountability committee James Comer he
is now demanding that the National
Archives turn over for all documents and
Communications featuring Robert L Peters
and two other pseudonyms that were used
by Joe Biden now Comer is especially
interested in emails that included
Hunter Biden and two of his closest
business partners Devon Archer and Eric
schweren now chairman Comer is also
requesting drafts from Biden's 2015
speech to the Ukrainian Parliament
that's because Hunter's business email
was cc'd on numerous government
documents sent by Robert L Peters
including at least two emails involving
Ukraine and it looks like the big guy
was possibly sending drafts of a speech
to the Ukrainian Parliament to his son
Hunter who at the time we know was
addicted to drugs and had no experience
in Ukraine energy or oil now very
strange to say the least at the very
same time Hunter was getting paid big
bucks to serve on that oil giant Ukraine
known as barisma that's the oil and gas
company and we all know his background
he has them and with all the other
suffering that he had from his
addictions how is HE capable to make all
these million dollar deals in a business
that he had no background or experience
in that's a great country if you have a
great job if you can grab that one now
the owner of Barista even reportedly
thought according to that 1023 form that
he believed that Hunter Biden was stupid
and that his dog was smarter than Hunter
and don't forget
I I didn't say it the guy did
um his father Joe Biden claimed to have
no involvement at all whatsoever he
never once discussed with his son Hunter
his brother or anyone else for that
matter their Farm business deals but the
timeline we're about to show you
suggests the otherwise let's start the
date December 4th 2015. now Hunter is in
Dubai and he's with the bosses at
barisma and at that point they're
putting a lot of pressure on Hunter and
his business partners that they need to
call D.C they need help from D.C to
address pressure that the company was
facing and according to testimony from
Devin Archer quote they requested that
Hunter help them with some of that
pressure Archer said quote you know
government pressure from the Ukrainian
government investigation now five days
later exactly five days later December
9th same year 2015 then Vice President
Joe Biden was in Ukraine how convenient
that's where he delivered remarks to the
Ukrainian Parliament now this was a
speech carefully crafted to put pressure
on the government to take action against
individuals who Biden deemed corrupt
take a look
because it's not enough to set up a new
anti-corruption Bureau and establish a
special prosecutor fighting corruption
the office of the general prosecutor
desperately needs reform the Judiciary
should be overhauled the energy sector
needs to be competitive ruled by market
principles not sweetheart deals it's not
enough to push through laws to increase
transparency with regard to official
sources of income senior elected
officials have to remove all conflicts
between their business interest and
their government responsibilities
every other democracy in the world does
that system pertains
now the irony is on that very same day
after that speech on December the 9th
2015 hours before returning to the U.S
Joe Biden that's the moment that we got
him on tape bragging about that's when
he leveraged 1 billion U.S tax dollars
in loan guarantees to force Ukraine to
fire a prosecutor and get rid of him out
of office the prosecutor was the very
guy that was investigating not only
barisma the oil giant but also his son
and his son's company for corruption and
Son of a bee they fired him remember I'm
leaving here in six hours if that
prosecutor is not fired you're not
getting the money well son of a beat he
got fired and according to Archer this
kept the doors open at barisma or he
thought they would go bankrupt for at
least a few more years and Hunter he
benefited from that firing because he
continued to get paid in other words
Biden Family Enrichment and like the
1023 form he said official actions as
vice president resulting in money for
the Biden family for a guy that was
addicted to drugs that had no experience
does that make sense to anybody does
that sound like Joe never talked to
Hunter or anybody for that matter about
this their foreign business dealings now
a few months later now in May of 2016
Hunter's business account was included
on a government email to Robert L Peters
about an upcoming Biden phone call with
Ukraine's president quote uh Boss 8 45
a.m prep for phone call with parashenko
the president at the time and Hunter
Biden was the only person cc'd on the
email why would why would he be telling
his son about a discussion with the
Ukrainian president keep in mind this is
not a one-off incident there are
pictures of Joe Biden hanging out with
numerous Hunters foreign business
partners dinners at Cafe Milano one case
with the former first lady of Moscow
Russia oligarch three and a half million
dollars she did in business with the uh
Hunter Biden uh company and then later
120 million dollar investment in their
real estate division over 20 phone calls
Devin Archer testified to the house
oversight committee with Hunter and his
son's Farm business partners and a
damning Shakedown what's that message
you might recall between Hunter uh and a
Chinese business partner remember the
one I'm sitting here with my father and
would like to understand why the
commitment made has not been fulfilled
Hunter continued I will make certain
that between the Man City next to me and
every person that he knows and my
ability to hold a grudge that you will
regret not following my direction I am
sitting here waiting for the call with
my father a few days later Hunter
received a generous five million dollar
wire from these very same Chinese
business partners in the oil business
yet again Hunters lawyers say the what's
that message is fake well Congressman
Comer who will join us in a minute he
says that's called evidence and that
experience that evidence shows that Joe
Biden and the Biden brand as Devin
Archer called it was for sale and that
the brand it wasn't Hunter it was the
big guy it was the vice president of
this country at the time and apparently
his family was getting paid one way or
the other the house oversight committee
has identified nine Biden family members
that got money including the grandkids
what did they do for that money what did
Hunter do for all these millions of
dollars in tax and in emails Hunter
talked about having a fork over half his
income to Pops Biden was also reportedly
allocated 10 percent 10 percent a cut
you know for the big guy in one of these
deals Hunter worked closely with the
company's business manager to pay large
very specific sums of money to pay for
Joe's home repairs and on this issue
breaking this week a newly uncovered 20
2018 texts from Hunter complaining quote
my dad has been using most lines of my
account which I've through the gracious
offerings of Eric schwarin have paid for
the past 11 years in other words Joe's
getting his cut now Eric schweren was
Hunter's main U.S business partner in
this lucrative a lot of these lucrative
deals including with China this does not
look good for Joe Biden who's now
president or should I say Robert Peters
and guess what it's about to get a lot
worse as Comer's investigation continues
but by the way without a diversion
agreement the president's son Hunter he
might soon be headed for prison for a
gun law violation that his father
enthusiastically supported hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else